correspondent charlotte bellas is in
kabul and she headed for the airport
very soon after the attack and she
describes what she saw
we initially heard the explosion around
5 40 p.m
we headed towards the scene and there
was chaos as you can imagine there was a
lot of gunfire as the taliban tried to
push people away and control the scene
we tried to move closer towards abbey
gate we heard another explosion
there was more heavy gunfire there was
hundreds of people running towards us
and there was heavy smoke in the air we
heard sirens coming from the airport and
the taliban fighters that guard that
that south gate where we had arrived
we're pushing everyone back quite
frantically they were panicked
themselves uh a few ambulances drove
past us and and we stayed there for
about half an hour and heavy gunfire
continued throughout we've tried to talk
to
us military forces over this time but
they they are keeping quite uh quiet
about their operations
but we do know that three u.s soldiers
were injured and i was just down there
earlier this week at this exact location
at abbey gate and the taliban don't let
you film around the airport's perimeter
so i used my phone to film and capture
some of what was happening there were
hundreds of people around abby gates
this was just a couple of days ago there
were taliban checkpoints around there
and then there's a there's a post with
three americans in it at that time that
were overlooking the scene at the top of
about a three meter high concrete wall
surrounded by barbed wire and they were
overlooking the hundreds of people
trying to get through people below them
were waving pieces of paper saying you
know i i deserve to get on some of these
flights here's my certificate from
working with the americans and what have
you and and they had the gate closed at
that time just overlooking the scene we
heard of an isil threat
earlier this week it didn't seem to
deter anybody but then it was only
coming from the us and it was quite
vague
over the last 24 hours or so
there were more threats issued by
various countries talking about this
this isil threat i contacted the taliban
this morning to ask if they knew any
more details about uh have any more
intelligence on it they said uh from
what we understand isil is planning some
type of car bombing in and around the
airport and that they're looking for
maximum damage
after we received that we decided to
stay clear of the airport today as did
other media networks uh who we had been
going down there all of us every day but
today most people stayed
clear because there was the threats
level and then the amount of information
we were getting was getting more
credible and coming from more sources
and uh it was more kind of watch and
wait i i do have to say that my producer
ducked down there briefly just to have a
quick look from a distance and he said
there were far fewer people down there
today that the taliban were incredibly
tense and that's saying something
because they've been tense or weak uh
but very much pushing people back trying
to keep them at a distance from the
airport
and were quite agitated when he got down
there and they told him to leave
immediately so everyone was on alert
today but at abigail it appears that
there had been crowds forming and that
they hadn't managed to disperse them
when this explosion occurred
well let's now cross back to washington
dc and speak to alan fisher he has all
the latest lines for us out of the
pentagon alan we are hearing
confirmation that four marines were
killed in this attack what more do we
know
that information was given to staff at
the u.s embassy in kabul by the
ambassador he confirmed that four
marines had been killed three had been
injured certainly the pentagon has in
the last 20 minutes put out a statement
confirming that there have been a number
of american casualties and we should get
more details on that when the pentagon
is due to brief in about 90 minutes time
uh certainly in 24 hours ago because
they were aware of this threat that had
been made by isil that there was the
potential for an attack at the airport
the marines on duty there had been given
advice on what to look for for a
potential suicide bomber even though the
even with that they continued to process
people through the gates they were
trying to get them on flights and get
them out of afghanistan but
interestingly enough the numbers over
the last 24 hours dipped quite
significantly from the numbers that
they've been doing since the start of
the week that may have been because of
more security checks that at the moment
is just mere speculation but something
obviously that the americans will want
to look at we know that lloyd austin who
is the defense secretary has been with
joe biden he was in the situation room
at the white house they were talking to
commanders on the ground also there was
anthony blinken who's the secretary of
state and then lloyd austin went back to
the pentagon they will be looking at how
they carry out operations from now on in
certainly 24 hours ago the pentagon was
saying that there was the potential that
troops may well be used in kabul itself
to go and get americans who are stranded
given that the information coming from
the embassy in kabul is for americans to
stay away from the airport stay away
from the gates because they were aware
that this potential attack could
actually happen it means that that is
more likely to be the way that the us
conduct their operations from now on in
certainly joe biden had asked for
contingency plans if this operation were
to extend beyond the 31st of august it's
a fluid situation contingency plans
continue to be updated and we can guess
that that's exactly what's happening at
the moment alan fisher there with the
latest lines for us out of washington dc
thank you so much alan well let's now
bring in marwan bashara he's al
jazeera's senior political analyst and
he joins us now from paris as we were
hearing there from alan marwan and these
confirmations of deaths amongst u.s
troops in these attacks in kabul surely
that only increases the pressure on
president joe biden after what's been
really a rather humiliating week and a
half
absolutely
as we were
speaking earlier the next seven eight
days will prove to be the longest in the
life of this 78 year old president
it will also be some of the longest days
for many afghanis and americans and so
on and so forth these are really testing
times
clearly 20 year war did not go down very
well
but also as you and i were speaking
certainly uh joe biden and his
administration and his intelligence
community bear
some
of the blame certainly on the
operational level and some of the
strategizing going forward in terms of
the drawing but just to make it clear
this deal the deal for withdrawing
american forces from afghanistan was
signed by president trump
the short-sightedness the disaster of
this recent thing
started with the idea that america will
negotiate with the taliban and the
taliban alone without bringing in the
afghan government the other afghan
factions and certainly without bringing
any of the neighboring countries so what
you had in the process of the
negotiations with the taliban is totally
legitimizing the taliban and as i've
written at the time it was looked like
surrendering afghanistan to the taliban
so biden really is now inheriting a
certain crisis that was brought about by
his predecessor president trump and just
to add a bit to that and to remind our
viewers around the world in in in few
seconds
that that this has been a long long time
coming 20 years
you know this started as
a as as a war of revenge uh you know
avenging the 9 11 attacks wars of
revenge are never a good idea they're
not credible they're legitimate and they
don't work and then it was followed by
another war of choice against iraq and
when both wars were finished
they decided not to withdraw and leave
the middle east or withdraw their troops
they decided they wanted to change them
at least
you know the idea of a of a crusade by
the west on on you know on the top of
the military to change the muslim world
is not exactly a good idea and that does
inflame hatred does empower insurgencies
whether it is in iraq or afghanistan and
we've seen that happen and we've seen
counter intelligence growing we saw the
taliban power growing and we saw all
that possible solution from the idea of
clear build and whole and the idea of
the afbac and this and that and the
other training the locals and
none of that were but but the pentagon
continued as now we know from american
press reports
that they continued to lie about it
they kept on saying it was working they
were succeeding but in fact they were
failing
so biden today is dealing with a
catastrophe that has been in the making
for some 20 years now
marwan you talk there about this war of
revenge and the aftermath of of 9 11.
how significant is the attacks today and
i ask you this because
a lot of this was about well the groups
that the taliban was harboring in
afghanistan and now if the taliban is
proving that they can't necessarily
prevent attacks like this from taking
place and and that there are other
groups who could be operating in and
around that area does that change the
political calculus and the military
calculus going forward here for western
powers
you know your question is uh
you know it really
presents very well the paradox of this
whole
crisis this whole blunder this whole
debacle because what do you have here
what do we have today we have what we
have a situation is after 20 years and
four american presidents
you know they they got rid of the
taliban in order to replace them with
the taliban it took 20 years and for
president to replace the taliban with
the taliban
a taliban today that is far more
powerful than the taliban of 1996 with
the 19 or 2001. so clearly these are the
marks of this disastrous war this you
know war of revenge as it were
that they continued to lie about it
and yes in the process what we have
today is not only al-qaeda we have
al-qaeda we have the taliban and we have
isil and as we've seen in iraq and syria
afghanistan and elsewhere in africa and
asia isil turned out to be even more
vicious
than al-qaeda and the taliban so clearly
the situation now does not bode well for
this 20-year experience and clearly this
is the time once the next seven eight
days are you know gone by
to draw the lessons and what are these
lessons clearly joe biden has proven to
be smarter than the rest in the sense
he's saying look we need to
end the never-ending wars period
and we need to stick to some of the
deadlines period and we cannot go back
and fight and even today
you know the israeli prime minister in
washington
was going to be there nagging and
demanding that they're not to stay and
hold the fort against iran and and drop
the diplomacy in favor of what
the united states does not want to go
into another war in the middle east so
that's at least that one lesson seems
for the time being for the time being to
have been learned
that the idea of conventional wars the
idea of counterinsurgency does not serve
american interests and does not
does not uh end terrorism
but that takes us just quickly to this
another
paradox of this whole thing so while the
binary administration decided to stop
all efforts of counterintergency and
conventional war and deployment of
troops on the ground
it is
sticking to the idea of the war on
terror meaning not counter-intelligence
but combating terror
meaning not doing it physically on the
ground with american troops by doing it
by drones missiles
special operations and so on and so
forth to my mind that will create more
of the same hatred more of the same
animosity and more of the same
extremism and radicalization in the arab
and muslim world so while
counterinsurgency on the ground in iraq
and afghanistan elsewhere was not a good
idea but also the idea of war on terror
throughout the muslim world using drones
and special operation will also prove to
be inflaming the souls in afghanistan
pakistan and elsewhere in the muslim
world so that's lesson
number two meaning you're gonna have to
find a better way of how to deal with a
question of terrorism
in a way
that is more in partnership with some of
the countries in the region more through
diplomacy and development and less
through war and violence
marwan bashara there al jazeera's senior
political analyst speaking to us from
paris thanks for sharing your thoughts
with us again marwan thanks for being
with us
well let's now move over and speak to
our white house correspondent kimberly
halcott kimberly as marwan was alluding
to there president biden was supposed to
be meeting the israeli prime minister
today but that hasn't happened and he's
ended up spending most of his day in the
situation room instead
we know that the president is getting
regular updates and so we expect that
that is happening in the situation room
because
in terms of how the president is getting
this information it is coming through
very secure and classified channels and
that is the only place in the white
house where that can be assured
so we know earlier today that the u.s
president and commander-in-chief of the
u.s military as he has also known was
meeting in the situation room with the
defense secretary the secretary of state
the chair of the joint chiefs as well as
the vice president who is flying back
from a tour in asia but participated
virtually from air force two now what we
know is that the much of the
intelligence following these explosions
was being shared in real time with these
intelligence officials and security
officials and they were coordinating
with the commanders on the ground now
we do know that in the case of lloyd
austin the defense secretary that he is
now back at the pentagon uh but we
expect that some of those briefings are
continuing with high-level senior
administration officials so the what the
white house is confirming for us is that
the president's schedule has changed so
that he can can continue
to get these briefings and so what that
means what isn't happening
is uh that there is no longer white
house press secretary briefing with the
white house press secretary jensaki the
planned bilateral meeting between the
israeli prime minister naftali bennett
as well as u.s president joe biden has
been delayed we don't know if that will
happen today i suspect not
but we've had no word on when that is
being rescheduled in fact most of the
israeli media has now left the white
house campus and is either congregating
at the willard hotel
or at other locations and we can also
tell you that the virtual meeting
between the u.s president and some
governors around the united states these
would be the heads of some of the states
that have offered to
house some of the afghans who have been
evacuated that has been canceled for now
so
what we are expecting is to get some
sort of update about when we will hear
from the u.s president because the big
question and the pressure is growing on
him with respect to the august 31st
withdrawal date for u.s troops the u.s
president had been holding firm on that
date but he said that that was
contingent on the taliban ensuring that
there was safe passage to and from the
kabul airport so the evacuations could
continue we know
that the state department halted those
evacuations urging people not to go to
the airport because of concerns of an
imminent threat of an attack and then
these twin explosions occurring at the
abbey gate and kabul airport
and also the barren hotel so as a result
uh there has been a lot of criticism
on the u.s president about the handling
of this situation and that's why we're
watching very carefully to hear from the
u.s president indeed kimberly the
taliban is saying that this attack only
happened because of the presence of
foreign forces on the ground and they're
saying it also took place in an area
which was actually controlled by the u.s
by their security forces and now there
are obviously four dead marines who were
killed in these blasts and does that
change the political calculus when it
comes to withdrawal
what it changes is the political
narrative because what we have is a bit
of a
pr
war that is being waged between the
taliban and high-level americans
including the
most prominent uh
senator on the foreign relations
committee the bob menendez who's been
very critical of the taliban in fact he
released a statement condemning these
attacks and blaming the taliban for them
occurring given the fact that it was the
us's understanding that the taliban was
making sure
to and from the airport would be secured
from any sort of imminent danger he says
as we may wait for more details one
thing is clear we can't trust the
taliban with american security this is a
full-fledged humanitarian crisis can
also tell you the president's republican
critics on capitol hill are also very
very unhappy seething as a result of the
news of these attacks and the deaths of
at least four americans one
republican congresswoman accusing the
president of having blood on his hands
another a veteran of the u.s military
representative dan crenshaw saying we
are still at war
accusing president biden saying you
didn't end the war you just gave the
enemy the new advantage and he is urging
the president to go on the offense that
is certainly something that potentially
the president is considering as the
pentagon has drawn up contingency plans
we also know that another prominent
senator who has been more hawkish with
respect to military issues senator
lindsey graham a republican has said
that i urge the biden administration to
re-establish our presence at bagram as
an alternative to kabul airport and
you'll remember just a few weeks back
that the u.s military very quickly and
quietly
left bagram and
isolated or rather desolate given the
fact that they abandoned it to shift the
operations to kabul airport so at least
one republican saying that that needs to
be rethought whether or not that's even
an option is really uh for the military
experts to answer but these are all the
unanswered questions that remain and so
that is why all the focus now is on the
president's schedule and we have not yet
had any updates but what i can tell you
is that all week things have been
rapidly changing things briefings have
been cancelled delayed and today is no
exception in light of these twin
explosions kimberly halcott there our
white house correspondent in washington
dc thanks so much kimberly
well let's remind you where this all
took place these twin attacks happened
as large crowds tried to reach kabul
airport in order to have a chance of
boarding a flight out of afghanistan
that first attack took place at the
baron hotel have a look down here people
who were hoping to be evacuated had been
congregating there and then a suicide
bomber struck the airport's abbey gate
crowds still appear to be ignoring the
warnings to stay away though while
british prime minister boris johnson is
saying that their evacuations will
continue despite these explosions near
the kabul airport
there's been a
a barbaric terrorist attack what looks
like a series of attacks in
kabul on the airport of the crowds at
the airport in which members of the us
military very sadly lost their lives and
many afghan casualties as well and we
extend our condolences
both to the united states of america and
to the people
of afghanistan
and i look i want to stress that
this threat of a terrorist attack is
one of the constraints that we've been
operating under in uh
operation pitting in in the the big
extraction that's been uh that's been
going on and uh
we've been ready for it we've been
prepared for it
and i want to stress that
we're
going to continue
with that operation
and we're now coming to
towards the end of it to the very end of
it
in any event and
we've already
extracted the overwhelming majority of
of those
uh under under both the schemes the the
eligible persons the uk persons the uk
nationals plus the
uh the afghans the interpreters
and others and it's been a totally
phenomenal effort by the uk there's been
nothing like it uh for decades and
decades
um but clearly uh what this attack shows
is the importance of uh continuing that
work in as fast and as efficient a
manner as possible in the hours that
remain to us and that's what we're going
to do
well earlier i spoke to rosella mitchio
she's the president of emergency that's
a medical ngo that's treating victims of
the blast in kabul and she told me that
her organization is still prepared to
treat even more patients
well let her seeing the usual disaster
of war um we have to receive more than
60 patients now um and six dead on
arrival so
the the the impact of this blast has
been huge
all of them civilians
and they're keep coming so uh we don't
know exactly how big
uh will be the number the influx of of
patients
we work there since uh 22 years and we
have faced a mass casualty so we do have
plans we do have extra beds the hospital
was eighty percent full
but we're adding uh beds on top of what
we already had uh then of course we once
we do the triage we will keep the more
severe cases the life-threatening
conditions and we try to reserve the
less severe cases even though in these
days
there are not so many hospitals uh fully
working in in kabul unfortunately it
it did not change um i mean our mission
criteria just slightly open to
also traffic accidents civilian traumas
because we started to receive in the
last couple of weeks a reduced number of
war uh wounded or injuries
but
but generally speaking we have been
keeping both three the three hospitals
and the 40 cleanings always up and
running all our stuff is coming both
male and female has been able to come
fast and we hope to be able to continue
our work uh also in the future
well to protect not really to get ready
uh
what we we we
try to do i mean our hospital been there
for a very long time and they've been
assisting everybody uh regardless their
uh political affiliation so it is uh our
naturality has been let's say our
insurance
uh since the very beginning and so far
it has been always respected uh so what
we do when we hear about these kind of
threats is to try and understand how to
get ready uh inside the hospital to
receive the massive influx of patients
as we are seeing today
we we have been in contact with the new
uh let's say authorities in
in kabul um that they hosted also um a
health cluster meeting uh to introduce
the focal points uh but so far we didn't
have any
um let's say interference or any special
request we have been able to keep on
doing our job as uh regularly as we did
before
no one uh none of them has been taken to
our hospital because we check everybody
so not only civilians but also
combatants
so
but at the moment as far as we know all
the
inju patients referred to our hospitals
are civilians uh some others because i
think that there are more than than this
uh
might uh might have been taken to other
facilities but they are very complex
injuries because
shells and fragments they go
they they produce multiple injuries so
when we see people with multiple traumas
legs arms face uh belly um particular
feelings are the vascular injuries
because uh they can lead to a very
sudden death so in this moment what is
very important is to do a very good
triage and of course the triage has to
go on and on continuously because the
patients have to be re-evaluated
so it's uh it's definitely a very
stressful moment for the hospital staff
well if you are just joining us here on
al jazeera let's remind you of what's
been happening there have been two
explosions outside kabul airport the
taliban is saying at least 13 people
have been killed many more injured but
medical sources are saying that that
number of dead could be as high as 25.
meanwhile the united states has said
four of their marines have been killed
three others are injured
and this all has happened after the
united states australia and the uk all
warned people to stay away from that
area around the airport because of what
they were calling an imminent threat
from an isil offshoot in afghanistan now
thousands though continued gathering
outside the airport they've been there
for days in hopes of fleeing the country
after the taliban took over while
witnesses to the attacks have been
describing what they saw when those
explosions went off
it was time for the evening prayer when
an explosion happened i saw about 70
vehicles carried around 150 injured to
the hospital
people were standing at the airport gate
for evacuation when the blast happened
my cousin was also wounded on his leg so
he brought him to the hospital
well the taliban has condemned the
blasts their spokesman tweeted and i
quote the islamic emirate strongly
condemns the bombing targeting civilians
at kabul airport
the explosion took place in an area
where u.s forces are responsible for
security
well let's take you now to a live shot
this is the white house briefing room
where the presser the press conference
that was due to take place has not
indeed happened and we'll be bringing
you that live as and when it does
this is al jazeera
[Music]